oh
la musique ne mettant que mon travail me
donne la possibilité d'en enseigner au
primaire et au secondaire parce que les
spécialistes dans les écoles on a la
chance d'enseigner avec les petits comme
avec league
donc j'ai enseigné quelques années
presque huit ans au secondaire
présentement je suis de retour aux
primaires depuis deux ans donc quand je
renseigne au secondaire savez bien les
ados un beau coup nous questionner donc
quand j'enseignais au secondaire mais
secondaire 5 en particulier m'a demandé
sur madame c'est que ça va me donner moi
ça n'a envie d'apprendre la muse et je
m'en veux travailler dans le bourg
je sais que ça va me donner je leur
répondais mais c'est une matière à ton
horaire c'est moi je le savais mais
matière parce que dans le fond je leur
enseigne et la passion de mon enfant je
fais de la musique depuis ce que je tout
petit donc je le savais moi dans le fond
il n'y avait aucun doute que la musique
est importante à l'école mais la vraie
raison
mais la vraie raison sincèrement aucune
idée c'est pas moi qui nous a donné la
réponse c'est ma directrice adjointe
donc on va se poser la question
la musique pourquoi
trois aspects le cerveau s'envola musée
la médecine et la musique
oui la médecine et bien sûr les émotions
et la musique le cerveau commence on va
regarder un petit peu comme ce que mon
cerveau quand je fais de la musique ce
que le fonctionnement de mon cerveau on
va aller avec un enfant un jeune enfant
qui a pris le maquis après la musique en
jaune or avec une imagerie de résonance
magnétique la partie ça représente un
enfant qui apprend la musique la partie
b elle par contre représente un enfant
qui apprend pas du tout la musique les
zones en rouge si les ondes dans le fond
que le cerveau travaille quand la en
france réveille quand l'enfant fait
quelque chose qui est en action mais
c'est les zones rouges comme vous pouvez
voir sur l'image
donc dans la partie est j'ai pas besoin
de vous dire que il ya beaucoup plus de
régions du cerveau qui travaillent que
l'enfant dans le fond on n'y apprend pas
la musique l'eau je veux pas dire tout
de suite que ça vaut roll que l'enfant
va être plus intelligents malgré que il
ya des recherches qui tendent à dire que
l'apprentissage de la musique les
enfants qui apprennent la musique ont
accueilli beaucoup plus élevés un
quotient intellectuel beaucoup plus
élevé que un enfant qui apprend
lampaulais musique donc la musique c'est
un petit peu l'entraînement physique
pour le corps bain dans le fond la
musique est un entraînement physique
mais pour le cerveau des zones affectées
la mélodie vous voyez les zones 1 3 et 2
c'est les autres qui sont affectés par
le cerveau quand on a des mélodies les
paroles de la chanson a fait les hommes
comme vous voyez les autres zones qui
est au niveau du 4 5 6 7 et 8
ensuite la rythmique mais c'est le
cerveau nambot qui représente les 9 10
et 11
un autre image
un autre image vous voyez les zones en
bleu c'est la partie du cerveau qui est
mis en action quand premièrement que
vous écoutez descend une musique
familière vous battez la mesure vous
taper du pied
le chef d'orchestre 40 y dirige inventé
de la musique écoutée de la muse et puis
bien sûr bien au niveau des émotions
titanic de [ __ ] j'avoue les bas des
gens qu'ils l'on rit je reviens dans un
restaurant il ya plusieurs années puis
mais aimant la musique je voudrais vous
c'est une partie intégrante de ma vie
chanter chante depuis ce que je tout
petit donc je travaille dans un
restaurant où on prenait les commandes
nous pille on n'était pas loin quand
même de la polyvalente donc des clients
sur l'heure du midi j'ai besoin de vous
dire qu'on en avait plusieurs d'ailleurs
ça faisait la file comme moi j'avais une
très bonne mémoire que j'avais un excuse
pour travailler ma mémoire ben on
mettait aux commandes des sandwichs
parce qu'on avait absolument rien
d'écran pouvoir mettre en mémoire vous
avez juste aller dans certains
restaurants où on prend les seniors qui
ont des petits et grands moi j'en avais
pas ce que je faisais pour mémoriser
mais sa note si j'avoue que mes clients
trouvé ça tellement drôle parce que j'en
ai qui venaient s'asseoir justement à
côté de moi j'étais chanter puis je
dansais et oui chanter puis je dansais
sauf que on avait une consigne avec mais
que les filles avec je travaillais
c'était la seule que le droit de me
parler c'est celle qui est aux commandes
parce que si on faisait si j'avais
quelqu'un qui venaient me parler c'était
pas compliqué j'ai oublié ma suite puis
là je me met à faire des erreurs
est ce que maintenant je faisais des
erreurs dans mes commandes seulement
quand les filles venaient me parler
c'était rare que je faisais des erreurs
quand je prenais mes sandwichs j'ai pas
besoin de vous dire j'en avais des x 8 à
me souvenir une à la suite de l'eau
j'avais un ordre ou 6ème souvenu donc la
musique
ben ça aide aussi à la mémoire en plus
ben dans certaines écoles on va utiliser
par exemple pour apprendre des règles de
grammaire on va utiliser la musique pour
mémoriser des règles de grammaire
je vais vous montrer un court extrait
et qui a été réalisé par le cégep de
jonquière
dans une ville appelée gens car j'ai
longtemps cherché le ruc le mach est la
manière de mémoriser la vire direct de
gramat mais par ses pensées vont d'abord
me demander des métiers où vas tu vends
s'est avéré que amour à payer pour
m'aider de remplacer mon double est
mordu alors donc a eu un sens aigu non
on s'entend que ce genre de musique
l'eau nos ados ça passe pour à côté il
ya dans des geôles où on a un intérêt
certaines recherches ou s'ils tendent
même à dire que les enfants qui ont qui
apprennent la musique vont avoir aussi
une certaine facilité à mémoriser des
textes
donc c'est quand même déjà un autre
privilège j'ai moi même dans les salles
de classe au primaire déjà utilisé la
musique pour aider ça a l'air d'un drôle
mais les tables de multiplication
j'avais des petites chansons un auteur
je me souviens plus du nom et vous allez
petite chanson puis j'en ai une en
particulier c'était sur les tables de
multiplication
donc mes élèves travaillent et les
tables de multiplication durant cours de
musique je me faisais souvent souvent
dire madame ce don pedro ont fait 10
mètres avec vous j'ai même adapter la
même chanson pour les tables d'addition
pour les plus petites additions
soustractions pour les plus petits dans
mon travail aussi ça vaut même arrivé
que je vois utiliser parce que vous
savez la musique bat c'est l'art de
subdiviser le temps le musicien lui il
fait des mathématiques nick s'en rend
pas compte parce que dans le fond on
subdivise le temps valeur de ne fait que
je fais des mathématiques - la journée
puis on s'en rend pas compte mais quand
ce fait réaliser 100 en france on le
bain voyant jeu pendant un cours de
maître - mais non mais faut qu'on peut
faire travailler très facilement les
fractions plaidé signal donc je vais
vous montrer un petit exemple un exemple
de mon matériel que moi j'utilise en
classe une fameuse pizza
ben vous avez juste à penser en même
temps on a tout utiliser ce que vous
avez déjà sur les pointes de terre pour
apprendre les fractions ans le tiers
on a tous travaillé avec des pointes de
temps mais on peut faire exactement la
même chose avec les valeurs de nos moi
je travaille tous pour faire comprendre
les cheveux indicateur fait que ça
devient facile pour les enfants c'est
concret moi j'aime beaucoup le côté
concret saviez vous que dans certaines
recherches
on a même démontré que les gens se
fendant et ma foi on entend beaucoup
parler de la maladie d'alzheimer
la musique peut aider à ralentir la
progression de la maladie
même dans certains cas des gens qui ont
quand même perdu certaines parties de
leur mémoire la musique rythme faire
venir certains éléments dont a parlé le
mans être donc on s'entend que la
musique et nous au niveau de la mémoire
allait quand même très utile saviez vous
que dans la grèce antique pour former un
bon atteignons faire un petit peu
d'histoire pour former un bond
atteignant on devait travailler le côté
physique on devait travailler leur
oratoire et en plus je vais travailler
la musique les jeunes garçons apprenez
ces trois matières l'eau ce qui
permettait aux jeunes athéniens d'avoir
une santé y est très bien équilibré en
tant qu'être humain savez vous que même
dans certains pays en une dans certains
hôpitaux on va utiliser des musiciens
dans les salles d'attentes
ils sont payés au même titre que
n'importe quel personnel de l'hôpital
imaginez un musicien pays au même titre
que l'infirmière il est dans salles
d'attentes
il joue de la musique pour en même temps
il ya vraiment bien sûr le temps des
patients qui attendent pour aller voir
le médecin genevois avec le temps
d'attendre qu'on aujourd'hui comme ça
serait agréable d'avoir violoniste sera
en train de nous jouer une sonnette ou
n'importe quelle pièce qui serait dans
la salle datant mais en plus de fois on
a même découvert qu avant les chirurgies
en faisant écouter de la musique savoir
à enlever un certain niveau de stress
donc à quel point on va prendre moins de
médicaments pour ans dormait il arrête
le rétablissement après vont être moins
d'ici 10 ans paris donc les type
d'hormone on a différents types
d'hormones qui fait que lorsqu'on joue
mais ça va dégager notre site et
l'andorre films sont nommés la morphine
une machine n'a plus rien
le sto sin la dopamine
le cortisol
la sérotonine ces hormones aux
influences notre corps autant au niveau
du strip avons diminué le strict il y
avait des neurotransmetteurs qui sont si
bien que ces hormones hausse écrit qui
fait que ce qu entre la chaîne et brisé
mais la maladie de parkinson qui
apparaît dans différents maladie qu'on
peut soigner avec l'aide de la muse et
je vous avoue que le prochain vous allez
peut-être le trophée spécial la grippe a
changé non ça reste des états unis dès
qu'on sache sorin h1n1 la grippe
savez vous chanter ça fait dégager
l'immunoglobuline à qui est un pur à la
première barrière de votre corps pour
finalement combettes le virus de la
grippe
mon âge et luce auger une de mes
collègues à l'école qui elle a commencé
le chant choral cette année et je me
suis dépêché de rentrer dans sa classe
sur c'est parce que je viens de lire la
femme dit non et j'ai dit j'ai lu que
quatre chanter en groupe lo binger 17
diminue la possibilité d'avoir la grippe
j'ai dit nous on travaille avec les
enfants je pense à toi m'a dit c'est
drôle que tu me dises saut à 17 1 à 4 g
- la grille mystère mystère
la dystrophie musculaire et les maladies
pulmonaires
ça va un petit peu la dystrophie
musculaire qui la dégénérescence des
meufs vos poumons fort des murs un
volontaire parce que quelque part vous
choisissez pas de respirer donc les
maladies pulmonaires relax j'ai de mes
élèves
comme je vous dis qu'ils étaient pas
questionner mais pas du tout j'arrive à
autant de choisir les instruments qui
nous disait ben moi un nom je prends mon
instrument à un jeu fait de l'asthme ok
un instrument à vent vous savez un
instrumentiste avant ma utilise ses
poumons pour faire jouer dollar pour
jouer de son instrument et doit être
ludique sans système pulmonaire
donc je le regarde je dis ok tonnes
maladie pulmonaire se fait de l'acte au
contraire tu devrais jouer je raconte
des histoires mon cousin mon cousin qui
faisait la dystrophie
il a atteint la rive pm10 chante elle a
dit je comprends poa d'une médecin il ya
dix ans par cousin de jouer de la flûte
à bec
je le regarde je dis moi je pense que je
comprends pourquoi puis je vois que
ledit vu que sa maladie fait dégénérer
des générations au niveau de fond ses
poumons ainsi que de jouer d'un
instrument à vent ça augmente sa
capacité pulmonaire
bon je vous dis pas que ça le guéry
l'eau mais ça a quand même aidé ou au
niveau de ses capacités pulmonaires
j'avoue que mes élèves quand je leur
raconte insurge entendait plus parler de
ce parti
le tdi empêche la maladie du siècle de
nos enfants si vous suivez un petit peu
les nouvelles
vous avez sûrement entendu parler de ce
temps le québec est une des régions dans
le manque prescrit le plus le fameux
rite halal mais will 30 du siècle chez
nous à en faire ce pas drôle certaines
recherches tendent même à dire que
l'apprentissage de la guitare mais pas
n'importe lequel
la classique en particulier parce qu'il
ya dix ans au niveau de la classique qui
agit au niveau de votre système dont
pourrait faire le même effet que le
ritalin
incroyable mais vrai bon j'avoue que
j'ai une demoiselle chez nous qui du
père actif mais plus jeune est du maroc
aurait dû savoir savant fait que c'est
donc jouer de la musique
ben saeed au niveau du strip salle
hearst un petit peu aussi comme une
bouée de sauvetage pour eux ça les aide
aussi au niveau de l'estiment de soins
bongo une dame s'appelle c'est une
madame escient à vienne dans le coin de
mousse qui a travaillé à l'université du
québec à rimouski l allure jeune garçon
jeune garçon a été diagnostiquée telle
erreur jenson george pipas décidé de
faire suivre des cours débutants s'est
rendu compte que son fils était plus
qu'un la réussite scolaire était
meilleure ils y apprennent à mieux sauf
s'il y avait une meilleure réussite son
estime de soi c'est intéressant il était
bon le jeune homme est à l'université
dans les hautes études supérieures puis
à 22 2 qui a jamais eu besoin de
médication
linda et siame dick appréhende la
guitare permet à l'enfant hyperactif sur
ça vient pas de moi ça vient d'ailleurs
d'améliorer son comportement sa
motricité et son apprentissage en classe
faire de la musique lui donne aussi le
goût de la réussite
finalement le goût de l'alcool l'autisme
selon son spécial puis vraiment spécial
j'ai travaillé dans un service de garde
il ya plusieurs années puis j'arrive
dans mon groupe avec un groupe de deux
ans je travaille avec des enfants d'un
an et demi jusqu'à les ados donc j'étais
petit bonhomme et là je rentre dans mon
local aps les éducatrices me dise est
dans son coin iguerande occupe-toi
zambon une enfant coin grande cape town
en repos ok j'ai de la misère avec cette
partie l'autre vu occupe-toi impôts -
les enfants j'adore / je pas capable de
laisser un enfant comme cela je vois mon
petit bonhomme je me suis dans mon local
avec mon bon radio ma flûte traversière
mon petit bonhomme migrants pied dans
son petit coin tu vraiment petit
bonhomme je me dis comment je vais faire
je commence à jouer de la flûte mai des
z'arts que les enfants connaissent nos
jeunes sous quand je présente les
instruments à vent tu faisais des
chansons j'en ferais rejoint au clair de
la lune le thème de passe-partout toutes
les enfants qu'on insulte des fois il se
met même à chanter avec moi quand je me
mets à jouer donc et mon petit bonhomme
et je commence à jouer puis j'entends
plus grand monde et mon petit bonhomme
est celle ci a dit me semble qu'ils
devaient pas réagi l'arrière finalement
je ne vais pas m'en occuper
je décide de continuer à jouer mes amis
autour de moins qu'eux aussi étaient
captivés de voir cette belle fille chloé
en argent c'était très impressionnant
devant cette affaire l'eau c'était
tellement beau avec mon petit bonhomme
lui décide d'avancer
je vous rappelle qu'il est impossible de
bouger dans son coin qui gronde tout ce
qu'il devait faire
ce n'est avancée qui vient s'asseoir je
sens inverse le moins bon je dis qu'est
ce qui s'passe jeudi va recommencer à
jouer encore mon frère jean peut-être
que je veux réussir à faire de quoi mon
petit bonhomme était si
payer l'eau jusqu'à ce qu'il fait lui je
parle de ça avec de mes amis j'ai dit
vous auriez parce qu'après quand j'ai eu
fini retourner dans son coin puis sir
maigron deux ans de ça avec mes amis
n'entend que j'étais à l'université
quand tu te suis imaginé que tu as enfin
en lui il voyait peut-être t notes de
musique
1 c'est tout c'est pas fou c'était comme
s'il voulait attraper mais sont mes
notes de musique
probablement que lui dans sa tête
d'enfant artistique qui les voyaient
l'extrait musical que je vais vous
présenter ben savez mon travail me donne
la chance de mettre travailler avec une
sorte d'enfant puis j'ai un groupe en
particulier de très grandes difficultés
d'apprentissage fantôme d'un court
extrait
ok dans ce groupe le ca un groupe avec
de très grandes difficultés
d'apprentissage quand je vous dis très
grande halle aux sports des titres cédés
grosses difficultés d'apprentissage j'ai
une petite fille j'ai entendu un petit
carillon sont claires l'eau c'est cette
fille là est tellement mignonne on
arrive à madame madame madame doit bien
entendu c'est moi qui joue c'est moi qui
joue jeudi ben oui voyons j'étais à côté
de toi quand tu as joué c'est sûr je
tente dans le même groupe g un petit
garçon lui c'est tellement spécial on
monte un image avec des sentiments
je travaille beaucoup au niveau des
sentiments avec ses enfants le fait
qu'on remonte un monsieur avec qui est
triste que petit peu il prend ses
baguettes d'exil au qui commence à jouer
du vélo j'ai tout besoin de vous dire
c'est l'âme saône tricks c'est triste on
monte une phase joyeuse mon petit
bonhomme et commence à jouer
c'est super joyeux donc la musique et
les émotions
franchement la musique pour être
crédible aujourd'hui faut toujours
parler du côté scientifique puis
médicale quoi qu'on est obligé de
toujours faire ce pouvoir vraiment dire
que la musique est important faut que
j'aille expliquer une maladie mon
cerveau la musique cette émotion j'ai
pas besoin d'eux dans le fond de
commencer à sortir tout parce que la
musique la musique a fait partie de
chacun de nous pour faire écouter un
extrait de charlie chaplin cette
expérience avec vous
m
bon ok on s'attaque à l'époque du cinéma
muet on n'avait pas de peyrol on n'avait
pas les trams qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
donc on avait souvent des pianistes qui
a accompagné la trême il était placé en
amont pays devait jouer ce qu'ils
voyaient
bon c'était comme ça à l'époque la
musique de m'exprimer finalement les
sentiments qui dégageait êtes sûrement
rendu compte quand charlie chaplin était
arrivé que la musique qui changeait pas
devenu joyeuse parce qu'on s'entend que
charlie chaplin déjà juste en le
regardant pomare iv qui a commencé il ya
eu un petit peu de neige qui est apparu
à fait comme un saut bien la musique
offerte aussi de petites effet l'eau
c'est une petite comédie c'est drôle on
écoute ses comics je vois faire écouter
un autre extrait mais celui là bas tout
à fait le même genre de film
ok pas tout à fait le même genre
d'extraits on s'entend plus là dessus
la musique on s'entend cas doit susciter
l'intérêt du public
si vous enlevez la trame d'un film puis
essayez le vous allez voir vous aurait
pu même matériel en quarts de sa vie que
la musique ça dégage des sentiments les
sensations je suis allé voir justement
un concert dernièrement j'étais assis
jeudi c'est drôle sur un oiseau il n'y
avait pas deux oiseaux jeu dans un
église on s'entend tous les oiseaux
c'est ainsi et on transfère dans ma
taille j'entendais toutes les images
l'eau mais la musique c'est son cas vous
fait fin elle a la possibilité de vous
faire voyager à travers le temps quand
on parle des composites en quel beau
voyage à travers le temps faire
travailler voyager à travers le monde
c'est officiel que la musique vont nous
faire de voyager à travers le monde
avant vous donner des images d'une fête
dans une faille ta cabane à sucre
prenez les belles chansons qui ont
rapport avec la cabane à sucre vous
allez avoir l'impression vous êtes à la
cabane à sucre
finalement une panoplie d'émotions que
vous allez ressentir à l'écouté de la
musique
vous savez la musique sport juste la
technique parce que c'est sûr que quand
on apprend on apprend des gammes bon
après tout des rudiments de base
les musiciens on a tout passé par l'eau
mais un bon musicien doit être capable
je veux mes amis qui me faisait du
chantage du quand tu joues et tu dis tu
me fais d'un juge
pourquoi j'ai dit était meilleur que moi
mais dit tu avais le don d'un chansons
joyeuses la rendent triste pour
complaire aux indices avaient dégagé des
émotions quand tu vois je dis
sincèrement me suis jamais rendu compte
de ce jeu vous et vous qu'est ce que je
vous ai présenté ce pot la vision d'un
scientifique mais pas du tout moi
j'étais une spécialiste en musique et
une pédagogie point de s'identifier
moi je sais que mon travail par mes
paroles parce que je dois faire à
chacune des journées ça va influencer la
vie de mes enfants de vos enfants
finalement des enfants j'ai des jeunes
mamans qui m'est arrivé madame jeu
tellement content je suis dit voyant m'a
dit mon petit copain 10 lève le matin il
regarde son horaire puis deemed maman
digitale mais content aujourd'hui j'ai
mon cours de musique
on verra c'est une belle journée c'est
parce que trois mois avant la madame
avait souhaité bonne chance avec son
office parce qu'il détestait la musique
la musique moi j'ai déjà vu des élèves
qui se prépare à décrocher de l'école
par la musique j'ai réussi à les garder
à l'école moi j'ai le goût de vous poser
une question puisque moi je le sais ma
matière allait plus qu'importante parce
qu'elle peut les influencer pis pour
justin bond dans diverses sphères aussi
que ce soit dans leur santé au niveau de
leur apprentissage
mais en vérité j'ose vous reposer la
question
la musique pourquoi